dans le privé c'est vrai que les
établissements je les dis sont beaucoup
plus luxueux plus confortable et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui fait en fait ce qui
attire en fait les familles de place et
enfin de mettre leurs parents justement
dans ces établissements parce que
l'apparence l'apparence est belle mais
en termes d'accompagnement on le disait
l'accompagnement n'est pas meilleure
dans le privé lucratif est moins
nombreux et moins nombreux il ya moins
de personnel dans le privé lucratif que
dans les ehpad publics et public
hospitalier
donc c'est vrai que l'intérêt du privé
c'est effectivement de proposer des
établissements des chambres qui sont
plus confortables mais en termes
d'accompagnement humain et c'est quand
même ce qui prime il faut le rappeler
pour les personnes âgées qui sont des
personnes qui ont besoin voilà qu'on
s'occupe d'elle qui ont besoin d'être
rassurés elles ont plus besoin de
personnel que d'une belle chambre si je
puis dire même si en finlande va pas
sans l'autre et évidemment qu'il faut
rénover les établissements publics qui
se détériore
donc je pense que en effet on ne peut
pas forcément se passer du privé du
secteur privé lucratif mais il faut
accentuer les contrôles pour empêcher
justement ces dérives et augmenter les
moyens humains dans tous les
établissements qu'ils soient publics
associatifs ou privés
[Musique]